All right, guys, welcome to another Wednesday Zoom call.
This is Kelly, Dr. Kelly with Connors Clinic.
I'm going to be presenting on what's called liver directionality.
So spring is in the air.
We're in full-blown spring now.
And when I think of spring, I think of spring cleaning, unfortunately,
but I think of how important it is that we maintain healthy bodies
and that spring is usually a time that I like to do a cleanse.
So we're going to talk about a little bit of different concept
that has to deal with what we need to do before we start getting into detoxification.
So I'm just going to get started.
So this presentation is called liver directionality,
amending and maintaining phase 2.5 and 3 of detoxification.
Now, if you've listened to any of Dr. Connors videos,
he talks a lot about detoxification, how important it is,
and he talks about the phases.
So traditionally, we are taught about phase one, detox,
and phase two, detox, and how important those are.
So we're familiar with those.
I was looking through the research about two weeks ago,
and I noticed that there was this really important new research finding.
I don't really know how I knew it is per se,
but I know that in all the functional medicine training I've had,
that I had not heard of it,
and I ran into Dr. Connors' office,
and I started to present the science behind it,
and for the first time in my life,
and I've won Dr. Connors for almost five years,
and he actually was surprised,
and he didn't know already the concept.
Usually when I go in and I run in and find something new
that I think is new, he usually graciously listens to me,
and then tells me a couple more things about it.
So we thought this was really cool,
and he alluded to it last week about this concept.
So I was going to do the research,
and I found this principle,
and I'm going to talk about it,
and then you could tell your friends about it.
And I coined it what's called phase 2.5.
So no one's really talked about this phase 2.5 yet,
and I think that it's a really important concept,
and you'll understand why it needs its own little name.
It needs to be called 2.5,
and then we're going to talk about phase three detoxification as well.
So let's just kind of do an overview of detox.
So basically phase one,
we're using oxidative processes,
so they have reduction or redox,
and we're also using hydrolysis.
So it's basically just getting toxins ready to get out of the body.
It kind of makes them actually a little bit more toxic,
but that's good,
because then phase 2 can come along in tagum,
and phase 2 is usually glutathione,
and you've always heard of that,
or master antioxidant molecule,
and master detoxification.
So the glutathione's got to be in check,
and the other two phase 2 processes are called sulfation
and glucoronidation.
Again, that's just getting toxins out,
so phase 1 and phase 2.
Every cell has on it this channel,
this protein channel called an MRP1 channel,
and that's basically an exit for all the toxins.
Okay, so the toxins make their way,
and what we really want,
we don't really want a whole lot of them to go to the skin,
but it's all that our skin is a detoxification organ.
So if that's overwhelming,
people can get skin issues,
so the majority of the toxins,
we really want them via the blood,
so this is blood right here.
We want them to go to the liver,
and to the kidneys,
and then we want them to go to the toilet,
eventually make them their way into the toilet out of our bodies,
so that our bodies are less burdened with toxins.
And again, I think of this,
and I think this is a great time to hone in on this.
So let's zoom in here.
So again, our two major detox organs
that we're going to talk about
are the liver and the kidneys,
specifically the liver.
Okay, so let's hone in.
Let's blow up, per se,
a liver cell.
Okay, so there's a lot of stuff going on in this liver cell,
but the most important part is that
you see over here on the left,
that here's the blood right here.
So those are those toxins running down,
and this little goblet do here,
that's black, that's hooked onto this.
This is, you know, what a toxin,
which is just,
that's a toxin.
So it's going into the liver cell,
and sometimes it has to go through phase one,
phase two in the liver cell,
because most of the majority of that is done in the liver,
that's our major detox organ.
So it's going through the liver.
Okay, so let's trace it here, it is there,
and then it's red and it's black.
Exiting, it's exiting through
the MRP2 protein channel right there,
so that transporter right there,
so it's going to go into the bile.
Okay, super important.
So it came through the blood,
went through the patocyte,
goes through the MRP2 into the bile right there.
So these little green things right here,
those are bile salts,
and bile salts are,
these go hand in hand,
so that when a toxin exits,
the bile salt is going to be escorted out with it,
so that it can combine
and get excreted into the small intestine.
Another important piece in this hepatocyte
is this PC right here,
that stands for phosphatidylcholine.
So the phosphatidylcholine is also excreted
with the toxin and the bile,
and it gets excreted so that the bile can maintain its fluidity
so that it's not just stuck,
and what happens when your bile gets stuck is you get stones.
So PC's really, really important,
and there's a big genetic defect that I see just a ton of,
I actually, home was I guess,
where I don't make this very well,
so I don't have a gallbladder.
I actually had to remove when I was 20,
and I betcha if I just would have been put on some phosphatidylcholine,
I bet I would still have a gallbladder.
But now I do, I take a lot of PC.
So you need the PC,
and you need the bile salts,
and they exit into the bile flow right here,
all together, very happy.
Okay, let's get into the bile,
and then let's be excreted into the small intestine
and make our way out.
That's the normal process of how toxins get out.
Now you could say that this is also a kidney cell,
but you change it.
It'd be blood.
It'd be going through.
It'd also be going through the MRP2,
but that's actually in the proximal tubule of the kidney,
and then it goes into your urine.
So the reason why I think this is important is because it shows
how important a bile in the PC is.
So again, we're moving out and down.
That's the directionality.
That's what we're terming this directionality.
So for major functions of bile,
I think bile is just very underrated,
and how important it is,
how when it gets stuck,
one of the bile's major jobs is,
let's just skip down here,
is to kill off bad microbes.
So God gave us this beautiful,
really, really acidic stuff called bile,
that gets excreted into the GI system,
so that it maintains
that really good balance of bugs,
of that microbiome,
or you don't have any toxins in there,
which is really nice,
if you have something that the bile is going to go through
and keep it really nice and acidic.
So I have this hunch that people who are not moving their bile,
there's a big chance that they're going to have
what's called SIBO,
so small intestinal bacterial overgrowth,
or SIFO, small intestinal fungal overgrowth,
and it's really no surprise.
If you don't move that bile down,
if it's stuck for a couple of reasons,
I'm going to show you in a little bit.
It's stuck right here, it's not moving.
Let's say that you don't have enough phospholcoline
or your bile salts or moving or you're inflamed.
You're going to be at risk for some gut issues,
so that's one of the jobs bile does.
Another job is fatty acid metabolism.
We all know that.
Everyone says, okay, well,
you know, bile is needed to emulsify our fat,
so pretty much that's usually one of the ones people can identify,
but another underappreciated function
of our friend bile is the excretion of waste products,
and I just showed you up here how we're going into the blood,
and then we're going out through the bile.
So excretion of the waste products is something
that is really important,
and I think that it's underappreciated with the bile.
And then it also maintains blood sugar,
the metabolism of it,
which is actually I did not know that,
so that was new to me,
and the function of bile,
so that was super important.
So, you know, we said that it digests our fat,
it regulates the glucose and cholesterol metabolism,
and then, again,
this is something new for me, too.
I had an idea that this happened in the liver,
but it actually is responsible for a thyroid hormone activation
through the bile caniculate there.
So, really important.
It's one of those foundations of health that I think that we really
need to make triple-check sure that it's working well.
And if you've been in the clinic,
and if you've been tested,
you know, we make sure that we're looking for liver stagnation,
bile stagnation, so you're probably in good shape.
But again, it's spring,
so we think of, okay,
or we make you sure that this is really, really in good shape.
So, and we talked about the GI flora in the motility,
and how if you don't have that bile flowing,
and I really think that that's one of the key reasons
people get recurring sebow,
and the leaky gut kind of plays along with that.
And then, we talked about how the bile salts combine
with the cholesterol and the phospholipids to get toxins
out of the liver into the intestines,
and then into the toilet,
or reabsorb via the enteropetic circulation,
and we really don't want the ore part.
We really want them the toxins to get to get to the toilet
and when we have that reabsorption
through the enteropetic circulation,
that's just a fancy word for the blood flow to the colon
and the large intestine in the colon area.
So then we get it,
we're actually just reabsorbing our toxins.
So, the toilet is where we want the toxins.
So, what limits bile acid production and secretion?
This is a really good question.
So, the two that we want to focus on today are endotoxin,
so basically that's when you have a bad gut.
That's another word for endotoxin is lapopolysaccharide.
So, we want to make sure that your diet is optimized
and that you're not eating anything that's inflammatory to your GI track,
or if you have an infection in there that we've cleaned it up.
And the other one I want to focus on is inflammation.
So, inflammation in your body will produce cytokines
that induce coli stasis.
Now, coli stasis is a fancy word for decreased bile flow,
or your bile's not flowing.
So, really looking at that inflammation piece,
that's where I started digging into the scientific research
because I thought, okay, well, if we're inflamed,
which, you know, 90% of the population seems to be inflamed
with a diet that, you know, that we're the standard American diet
and also we just live in a very toxic world.
So, inflammation, it produces those cytokines that induce
and I was like, induce bile stagnation.
Like, that's really interesting.
So, that coli stasis also induces an inflammatory response.
So, you can see how that's a vicious circle.
So, we're going around and around.
If we have inflammation, then we're causing bile stasis
and then the bile stasis causes inflammation.
So, we have to get to the bottom of this.
And then what can happen there is that those bile salts
can actually accumulate.
They can get stuck in that cell and that,
in that padocyte and that liver cell
and that can cause them to die.
So, let's take a different look.
So, now we had, I'm going to show you this one again.
Okay, that was our original one.
Let's show you the same hepatocyte,
the same liver cell when we're under an inflammatory state.
So, here's what happens is that you have those toxins
and they're trying to go through this organic acid transport protein.
So, that's the normal way.
Okay, so, they're trying to get in right here.
But what happens is when they get in,
they can go through phase one and they can go through phase two.
But what happens is, this is the drum roll.
Is that the channel, that protein transporter,
which they usually go through to get into the bile
during an inflammatory state,
this channel is pulled from the membrane.
So, what I like to call phase two point five,
that's where the toxins go from the middle of the padocyte
into the bile, that's a huge step.
It takes a lot of energy for your body to push that through.
Phase two point five under an inflammatory state
doesn't even happen.
It can't even happen.
And so, what happens is all these toxins,
they start accumulating in the padocyte
and the padocyte's like red alert,
red alert, this is not good, this is not good.
So, what it does is it starts transporting the toxins back into the blood.
And it also says, what do we do with all these bile salts
and it starts putting the bile salts in the blood.
So, we have this liver directionality going the wrong way.
I figured out that when this is happening,
this is what I think is called a Herk's reaction.
And I'm sure we can talk about that when I open up for questions.
But what better way to depict this is that that Herk's reaction is
we're pushing, we're giving, typically we're giving the patient
a lot of phase one and phase two upper regulators
because we think they need to detox, they need to detox.
Well, guess what?
If you don't have your inflammation under control first,
you're going to put those toxins right back in your blood
because they have no exit strategy whatsoever.
So, this concept of losing our phase 2.5
and going into the bile into the small intestine, that's phase three.
If phase 2.5 is shut down, boom.
So, I call this environmentally and genetically induced
intra-hypatic coli stasis.
So, you could just tell your friends that you just learned a lecture
on the environmentally genetically induced hepatic coli stasis.
Now, cool it is and how what it really means
is that we have to make sure that we're not inflamed
before we start revving up our detoxification.
Before you start taking a bunch of glutathione,
we better make sure that your gut is really, really taking care of.
So, the concept, inflammation,
shuts down the ability of phase 2 toxins
to be excreted from the hepatocyte via bile
to the small intestine, that's at phase 2.5.
So, make sure that, and we'll talk about strategies.
That's the next slide.
So, we'll talk about the strategies on how to cut the inflammation.
And then the other thing is that if you've had your genetics run,
if you have that PEMT SNIP, which I have a homozygous
and so do my children, thanks mom.
We have to make sure that we're, if we can,
what we're eating a lot of eggs and foods
that contain phosphatidal coline,
or that we're taking a product that has the phosphatidal coline.
So, we will get bile stasis, that coli stasis, really quickly.
And we don't want that.
And then we have to make sure, so phase 3.
Phase 3 is that if everything's running perfectly,
let's just say that we're back at right here at this perfect liver cell
and we're exiting, exiting out and we're in the bile.
The bile is flowing through.
We have to make sure that the phase 3,
so once the toxins are in the gut via the bile,
they need to not be reabsorbed into circulation via the colon.
They need to get out.
And in some cases, we have to use what's called binders.
So binders, as the word implies,
will bind those toxins in your gut
to make sure that they're not being reabsorbed.
And again, if you've been in the office,
we have a shelf full of phase 3 binders.
What's actually really exciting is that I presented this
to a nutraceutical company that I work for.
I do some lecturing, just lecturing and research for them.
And I presented this to the president,
the same PowerPoint.
And he was so excited.
He's never heard this.
He's been in the supplement industry for 44 years.
He's been in natural health for that long.
And he has never heard of this concept before.
And what he's doing for the Conor's clinic is he's actually going to be,
we're going to be formulating our own phase 3 binders.
And so watch for that because those are going to be really cool.
And again, we typically test you to make sure this is happening
that we're lessening the information.
And we do that in a couple different ways.
So you're covered if you've been in.
But again, if you have specific questions,
you can always hit up Facebook or set up a consultation
if you want to talk a little bit more about this.
So the solutions to this is decreased information first.
So we talked about that before.
Before we start pushing these phase 1 and phase 2,
make sure that your gut is working well.
Make sure that you're following the diet that you should be
because we eat no less than three times a day.
And it's an immune response every time we eat,
whether we like it or not.
So making sure that we're eating really anti-inflammatory diet
and that alcohol can really give your gut a hit.
So making sure that that's taking care of is super important.
I like to use a little hydrogen water if I feel like I'm inflamed.
Granted, that's not getting at the root cause usually.
It's because I had a donut or something.
But hydrogen water is really good at cutting that inflammation.
So is curcumin.
And this last part stands for decreasing reactive oxygen species.
So for instance on genetic testing, I always look for sod
and I always look for hydrogen peroxide production.
So sod would take care of the super oxide molecule
and that's a reactive oxygen species.
So that's something that goes wrong and does damage
and causes inflammation.
So I just make sure from a couple different angles
that we're covering someone's genetic predisposition
to being inflamed.
And that's a huge piece of genetics right there.
You can see right and black and white
if someone's going to be highly inflamed
and how we take care of that is case by case.
And it's really personalized which is really cool.
The next solution is to optimize phosphatideocolean status.
So make sure that if you've had your genetics done
that you know if you have the PEMT SNIP
and make sure that if you can't eat eggs
that you're googling, you're asking Dr. Google
what else you can do dietary wise.
I'm a big fan of getting nutrients from food first.
But if you need a good phosphatideocolean supplement,
sometimes we just have to do that.
I take a PC supplement a couple of times a week
just to stay up on the bio-flow
because again I don't have a gallbladder.
So I really have to make sure that I'm doing that.
And then you know it's really cool.
This is my spring cleaning.
This is my where you kind of go above and beyond
is to stimulate the bio-flow.
So you actually can do more to really push that liver directionality.
And I like to use bitters.
And what that supplement company,
the nutraceutical company is going to do
is they're also going to formulate for us a blend of bitters
from the Connors Clinic that we're going to use
to just liven up that bio-flow.
So stay tuned for that.
I'm also a really big fan of visceral manipulation.
I am not an expert by no means.
But that's how you can get that bio-flowing as well
using some visceral manipulation.
And gallbladder cleanses are super fun, not.
But they work.
And if it's appropriate, you could do that.
If you're not sure if you're a candidate,
again, reach out to us and we'll let you know.
We want to make sure,
and I think this is the ninth time I've hit on this,
is that we clean up our gut.
We make sure that our gut's nice and tidy.
And we don't have an imbalance in flora in there.
And that can be a big part of the seabull in the leaky gut.
So just make sure that you're following your diet
and you're trying to eat really clean.
And the last solution is to optimize that phase three.
And I just think of bind, bind, bind.
Just do not give,
don't give those toxins a chance to get back in your bloodstream
because your body worked so hard to get them into your colon,
to get them into that bile and out.
That we just do not want to give them a chance
to be reabsorbed.
Bad things happen when they get reabsorbed.
So that concludes the liver directionality power point.
So what I'm going to do,
I'm going to unmute everybody.
Okay, guys, the floor is yours.
Well, I guess we can't go one week without asking
for an update on the genetics test.
So I just got off the phone with Bob Miller.
And he is literally,
he's just waiting for the green light from Rutgers who
they are the big university that's going to be running the data.
And he just, he can't,
he can't, his company can't release the test kits
until they say so.
So it's really out of his hands.
I just keep brand.
I sure can't.
Everybody's praying.
So we were told,
come hack or high water,
the end of March.
So tick, tick, tick.
I mean, he's still that till Friday.
It's Wednesday.
So, you know, there could be a miracle.
So stay tuned.
Okay.
If we're,
I'm detoxing with the sonas and the foot baths and everything.
Are we just recirculating toxins if our bile is employing?
No, actually,
so you would be,
you'd be using the skin for the detoxification.
So.
With that would be okay.
That's what you'd be bypassing.
So even if you're inflamed.
So that's why I really am a fan of infrared sonas.
I'm a front of fan of sweating and foot baths.
Let's say you are just,
just inflamed from head to toe,
just for a couple of different reasons.
The skin is still a good way to,
to get those toxins out if appropriate.
Is there a foot bath that,
kind of,
yeah, we like the true right foot baths that,
because it's programmable,
so you can use the frequency.
So if you go into your right computer,
there's a folder called
ion pro wave.
And that is,
that is the folder that you can look through all the programs
that you can run your foot baths on.
I,
my family, we run our foot baths.
Dear daily of one of myself or my kids,
or someone we just are really a big fans of it.
So it's not a real foot bath.
Yes it is.
Well, I guess that,
what's your definition of a foot bath?
And I guess if we got to go back to that,
well, I thought you were saying you're running from
again, the computer,
I'm thinking of foot baths,
and you're still doing it.
Yeah.
And so the ion,
if you, if you go to the true right website,
you can see a picture.
So what it is,
it's a device that you plug into where your,
um,
actually, it's just on the front of it.
It's the bottom right.
There's a,
there's a jack plug and you plug it in there,
and then you put the device into a foot bath.
And then it runs,
not only that,
it runs the frequencies through.
So the,
um,
the detoxification one is excellent.
I really love the absting bar,
even for everyone,
because absting bar is ubiquitous.
So we really like running that one,
um,
you'd be surprised if they look like mud
and you get done sometimes.
Um,
so yeah.
Well, I'm sorry,
I'm confused,
but you have to buy a device.
Right.
It's about, um,
$200, I believe,
and it just plugs into your right,
and you use the same computer,
the same right.
It's just an accessory.
Okay, there's no chance of electrocution.
No, I,
I know.
That's a really good question.
Um, it's really kind of scary when you plug it in,
but, um,
I've survived probably 50.
So we've never had any issues with it.
I don't know what it has,
but you can call,
um, in order one on,
you can order online,
or you can call and order it.
I've used it for candida for about 10 days now,
and my energy is just wet.
None.
So am I doing too much?
Yep.
Yeah.
How much did you do if it's a chronic candida
that's been,
I mean, you've seen it for about at least 20 years.
Well, I wonder if your candida might not be related
to what we just talked about.
So the CFO,
the small intestinal fungal overgrowth,
I wonder if we should focus on moving your bile,
a little bit better and focus on,
um,
cleaning that up,
doing some,
the new protocol with the bitters,
where you're stimulating the bile flow,
and then you're doing like a push catch.
So the push would be the stimulation,
and the catch would be the binder.
And just remember,
when you're doing foot baths,
that they're,
they're taking out bad stuff,
but they're also can take out minerals too.
So I always take a couple extra mineral capsules.
Um, we have a couple different brands that we like.
I like designs for health off the top of my hat.
I just take a couple of those just to make sure them
and not pulling out my,
my minerals that my body needs,
because you can get fatigued from that.
Similar to what we do for the son is then.
Exactly.
Okay.
And then can you run two programs in one day or no?
It depends which programs.
Okay.
And then go back to the gallbladder.
Um,
frequencies on the.
rife.
The ball then to help your gallbladder.
And by the side.
Sure.
You could use.
Yeah.
You could use the,
the rife to support the gallbladder.
So, um,
supporting the,
the secretion,
like if you're trying to support the,
the,
the hepatocyte to,
to secrete in.
That would,
that would be,
um, using bitters.
So, again,
that's,
that's a product that we're,
um,
formulating.
And we will have that,
or you can just use traditional bitters as well.
You don't have a product here.
As yet.
Is that what you're seeing?
We don't have it yet.
Very soon.
So this is all new,
new, new,
new, the binders and the bitters are all new protocols for you.
For a conner's clinic.
Right.
Okay.
So how do you know when your gallbladder is ready to do the
push and catch and flip?
That's a good question too.
So, um,
you know, there's,
there's really no magic answer.
I guess it would be,
um,
you know, making sure that your,
your,
your inflammatory status is in check.
So how do you make sure of that?
Well,
you know, making sure that you're,
that you've had a good diet for a while.
And that,
you know,
if, if you have genetic defects that you may be a person who
wants to take the hydrogen water or you may be a person who,
um, really has to work on getting rid of hydrogen peroxide.
So really,
even though this is a quote unquote new protocol for us,
it's,
it's more where we would have caught,
you know,
the part of cancer in part of disease states is inflammation.
So that's not something that we missed on a case by case basis.
And that's where the genetics come in.
And that's where the cause of the cancer comes in.
So really,
if Dr. Conner's,
or I have put you on,
uh,
turmeric or cumin,
or any of the products,
um,
that help with inflammation,
if we told you to adjust your diet,
those are the lot of things that we are proactively doing,
because we've always known,
even before we knew this,
to face 2.5 concept,
we've always known that,
and everybody who walks in our door,
and everybody who works at Conner's clinic,
we all need work on our,
on our inflammation.
Um,
and so that,
that's kind of a tricky question where it's, you know,
we like to have people in the office kind of seeing where they're at,
but could you try and,
um,
you know what I think,
here's what I think,
let me back up.
I think that,
if you've ever had a reaction,
where let's say you took some glutathione,
or you took a new supplement,
and you felt like garbage,
it was probably because,
you were having a quote-unquote,
herks reaction,
because you were,
you were too inflamed.
So I kind of,
kind of just,
just see where the person's at,
and just modify,
you know,
where,
where, um,
you know,
most people,
if they've been in our office,
if we've done your genetics,
even if we haven't done your genetics,
and we've,
we've tested you out,
you could probably give a,
the bitters,
and the phase three binder,
a try,
and,
um,
at the same time,
you could do a,
maybe,
um,
more of a,
a really strict,
anti-inflammatory diet,
where you're really just eating a lot,
a ton of vegetables,
and just a little bit of meat,
or, you know,
just kind of modifying your diet,
um,
a little bit more,
that'll get your body started,
that'll get it,
give it that push,
like, okay,
because, you know,
it's like a cycle,
like toxins get stuck in there,
and then they go back in the blood,
and then they,
so it's,
it's really trying to just,
just swoop in
and get things going.
Unfortunately,
I'm always exposed to heavy metals,
and my butt,
my pond, one,
those,
all those anti-inflammatory detox pathways
are all messed up.
This is,
I'm,
I'm really safe at staying with this skin,
but I don't know,
yeah,
to the others.
Mm-hmm.
And that would be it,
if, if you,
um,
would just,
let's say that you tried the bitters,
and you tried just,
um,
eliciting them,
so, um,
you could get that,
get that going,
and just see how you feel.
A lot of the times,
we underestimate,
or we don't value enough,
how we feel,
and when we're taking something,
and that kind of goes back to that,
uh, presentation I did on the Goldilocks area,
our body is going to tell us a lot,
so, um,
you know, when,
when I started taking,
let's just say,
for instance,
I got diagnosed with cancer in December,
and I started taking the Nerf 2 product,
so the Nerf 2 product is pushing phase 2,
so it pushes it really hard.
What happened is I started to,
I started to break out,
like a teenager,
and I'm like,
what is going on?
Well, I know what was going on,
is that I pushed phase 2,
and I was too inflamed,
and so everything started going the wrong way,
for me,
and I didn't feel good,
so I stopped,
I stopped my phase 2,
I stopped pushing that,
I did some more tumouric,
I really, um,
cut out all sugar,
period, nothing even,
of the sorts,
and went a little bit more keto,
and then I went back on the Nerf 2 phase 2 detoxer,
and things are going really well,
so,
your body knows best.
Oh, I can read it.
Yeah, right,
I know it's difficult.
It's hard.
It is,
if it's safe to say that
we're all better off not eating meat
or having any sugar,
um,
well, I,
it's a pretty big statement,
but I think that sugar is,
I don't see a whole lot of benefit to it,
um,
but me, I,
I mean, I,
that's a tougher one,
but sugar, yeah,
I think that it's inflammatory,
um,
there's not a whole lot of,
of good things I could say about,
especially with cancer,
so you don't want to drive the warburg effect,
you don't want to have,
you know,
cancers thrive on glycolysis,
um,
some people have to really limit it down,
but you're talking about,
even the natural sugar and fruit.
Yeah, to an extent,
so some people with,
you know,
with some of those genetic defects,
where the cancer just sucks every,
you know, sugar molecule up,
they need to go more ketogenic,
or they need to go more plant-based,
um,
but to not drive that glucose pathway.
But not everybody.
And the gallbladder cleanses,
is it, um,
do you have to watch out for pancreatic,
um, inflammation of the pancreas?
Yeah, you want to be careful,
if you have,
mm-hmm,
um,
if you have,
do you know which one to choose that,
you would,
that would be too aggressive,
shall we say?
For the,
for the pancreatic,
when you have pancreatic inflammation,
and then you're going to,
you're going to go for your gallbladder cleanse.
For your gallbladder cleanse,
I just, I,
I really like to stick with just the,
the gentle ones that use the,
the olive oil.
So I can post the one that we,
that is our go-to for most people.
Mm-hmm.
I'll post that on Facebook.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Dr. Kelly.
Yes.
I do a lot of, um,
um,
sonas, a lot of infrared sonas.
And I do, um,
the animal every day.
Good.
And I have, um,
not all the time, but,
a couple of times a week.
I will notice that I have spots on my hand.
They kind of look like,
this is beginning,
but they're like pencil head,
are not pencil head,
but a racer head that's about the size they are.
Uh-huh.
And then in a couple days,
they'll go away.
I'm also starting to get like,
um,
freaks kind of,
I mean,
it doesn't look like blood poisoning or anything.
there's a lot of,
just freck marks actually on my breast,
where the tumor is,
Uh-huh.
So is this maybe an indication that I'm not
because I'm detoxing through my skin is what I think I hear you say?
Right.
Mm-hmm.
You know,
it's one of my pathways messed up
because I get so much of this.
And then also every once in a while I'll smell ammonia.
Okay.
Will you smell your skin or your urine?
Or what?
Like when I'm in the sauna.
Do you eat meat? I'm not much. I do eat some. I'll wear a sped if I eat anything.
Yeah, so it sounds like you you're definitely moving through your skin a lot and
there's some people who just just have a a greater amount of detox through their skin,
so they were all a little bit different. So if you notice that though that could be an indication
that you would want to you know make sure that that if you think that you're still slightly inflamed
just kind of take a look at several different areas and just kind of you know is it something
you want to add in like turmeric or is there something you want to take away do you want to back
down a little bit on your face or if you're underneath phase one or phase two pushers you know you
want to maybe back down on those a little bit you could just be overwhelming your your body's
ability to do that or you or you might want to add in a binder but you're doing so that's why we're
really sticklers on trying to keep everyone really hydrated and going to the bathroom having a
ball movement as much as possible because we want to keep those toxins moving out so I really like
that you're doing the the animals you know you might just want to kick it up to if you can maybe
two a day and see what happens to your skin just see if that's a better way of of just of starting
that seems kind of easy and then with the ammonia I like to do to just make sure that we're not
consuming a lot of meat because that'll stress those ammonia urea detox pathways so I'd start there
okay okay how do we know if we're inflamed what would be the appropriate
turmeric to take everything well I just as a general rule I like a gram a day so I think that's what's
in our curcuclear product from Conor's clinic and and again sometimes we have to look at lifestyle
a little bit harder before we look at pills but again I do I take my salt I do take the
curcum in myself so I would just make sure that that's your diet's looking really good
that you're that you're in balance with with the lifestyle things first but in it's just a really
tough question to answer like how do we know if we're inflamed or not I mean could be a couple I mean
you could look at labs and you could know your CRP is one of your best markers for inflammation
your CRP is elevated and you are inflamed so you know for anybody who really wants to kind of check
this out you could go to your doctor and get a CRP and run it by Dr. Conor's and I that would be or
we could run it for you that would be the tell tale sign of of of inflammation if you have brain fog
or I mean it's typically not in quote unquote regular blood work but it's pretty cheap
and every doctor should know what CRP is so it's a good marker to just see what's going on
but if you're not doing your best yet if you're not doing your best with the lifestyle stuff with
diet and making sure you're getting some exercise if you can and fresh air and all that do that stuff
first you know do that stuff and just make sure and then but if you think you're doing it absolutely
the best possible job then go ahead check your CRP and see where you're at what does that stand for
it stands for C reactive protein oh yeah I wondered about I'm out of my with the right and
grounding it okay with grounding the right itself like losing a grounding sheet
and just thinking there's somebody wanted to put up one of their whole bed
and we'll just use like hat if you're going to use it but if you need one but I just ran across
that pad that you would put your feet on and I've never I just thought I'd ask yeah I mean I'm
doing fine with the right I used all the time I go the ground and yeah you've got my wife
everyone's around I think there was a really nice discussion if you go to the Facebook page if
you're on now if you go to the Facebook page and you type in on the search bar grounding I think
that they they really went through in depth doctor Connor shared like the pluses and minuses so
I really think it's preference now I have a grounding sheet but I like Dr. Connor said on the in
the Facebook discussion I only have it at the the bottom of my bottom of my bed so I'm not sleeping
on the whole thing so you're gonna it's positive because you're grounding which is great and it's
negative because it's taking some of the right frequencies from you a little bit so um see what
you can get on off of the Facebook page and then if you if you don't get your answer post again
and we'll answer for you again okay and to uh atomize is the air in the room
with the right I actually personally have not tried that so that would be a good post for Facebook
to see um but others are doing with that okay
accessory yeah I believe so okay yeah okay guys do we have any more questions at all and no
it's a it's a it's a it's a really high-level topic so it's really cool that so many of you were
able to to join tonight and really the the big point is is that we just want to respect the way the
body detoxes and if we're gonna be doing any sort of spring detox you know clear like talk to us
just make sure you're not you're not pushing when you're in flame because if you start doing like
let's say you're just gonna start taking a bunch of glutathione and then you feel just terrible it
I mean that's a reason why so um look be on the lookout for the binder and the the bitters and then
we'll do another webinar on that and like how you'd want to do that and we'll do that in the next
couple weeks on um and what would that look like and who'd want to do that um and and how you do it so
if there are no other questions yeah yeah I can Christina okay um I just have a question regarding
MRIs um my oncologist would like to do a follow up MRI um since I was just diagnosed
in January I think she wants to kind of her baseline for size of tumor my preference was to request
an ultrasound and she has um really made it clear that she would like an MRI I'm not crazy about
having the contrast but I was kind of wondering if you would just weigh in and give me your feedback like
it's okay go ahead for the baseline is there something I should know to be able to detox the
contrast that I would get um is it not a good idea to have repeat MRIs I'm just kind of curious um
being new to the whole imaging stuff sure so that's a really great point Christina is that um we
you know we have to weigh risk benefits so you know definitely doctors when I wore those shoes and
wore that white coat walking in the hospital you didn't really put much thought into I would say
the sequela of having um having the contrast with these different scans and and what the knowledge that
you'd get from an MRI versus an ultrasound that the MRIs are much more they're able to um with less
margin of error tell you how big your tumors are so if you know you want to get down to more specific
more accurate measurements that's which that's what she's probably looking at she you know she
knows you can see it with ultrasound but there's a margin of error and and what they can actually
measure and then how and the reproducibility of an ultrasound is much smaller you know it's not as
good as an MRI but I agree with you is that um it's not without uh issues to have the contrast
and I would first ask her if they could possibly if if if she doesn't want to hear at all about the
ultrasound and um you could put on the table an MRI without contrast and just see what she thinks
and kind of ask her the pros and cons we do have um homeopathic remedies for the some of the contrast
dies um you'd want to just make sure you're super hydrated um you know make sure that you're um just
taking care of your diet before and after just lots of um you know if you can juice that would be
really good before and after keep your detox pathways moving so and is the homeopathic remedy or
support that you have to offer is it specific to the type of contrast is that important for me to know
or is it a general just detox you know so as far as I know um I am more familiar with the radiation
with that homeopathic remedy I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to phone a friend who is doctor
counters okay I'm gonna ask him and then we'll post that too okay that would be great yeah
all right I will definitely explore with her if we can do it without contrast that would be
to be my preference but if yeah um if she feels that that information is valuable then I will
definitely watch for your post about what to get for helping that pathway thank you perfect great
great question Christina thank you um my quick question was what what did you say about um what you
do to compensate for not having a gallbladder sure so um at first I used ox bile so I used
pretty much a supplement that had the bile in it to make sure that um that it was um absorbing
my fats but really that that's no replacement whatsoever so what I do is I make sure that I have
that phosphylcholine optimized and I make sure that um I am doing a lot of gallbladder flushes and
I'm using bitters so like I I've used bitters for a long time and I use them in streaks just to keep
that actual hepatocyte like flowing that liver directionality flowing so um you know it structurally
what happens is that the common bile duct kind of starts to get poachy and it's like a surrogate or
like a um you know a false gallbladder so it's not the biggest deal if you don't have a gallbladder
I mean there's how many millions of us poor souls walking around but um and it's everyone's different
so that's man sir but the bitters that you don't offer them yet but where could we get them just
any like health food store or I think yeah I think health food store carries them um it's basically
like dandelion and mer and genetion those are a couple good bitters anything that literally
tastes really better will help you move your bile so um but we're going to have one that actually
has some phosphatidolcholine in it so even if you have perfect phosphatolcholine making ability
it's still a really good idea to have it in there so getting the bile flow if you have flukes or
parasites blocking it how do you know that oh that's a good question that's a really good question
I don't know the answer to that I don't and I wonder if when we use kinesiology if the flukes
would come up first because we'd have to get rid of those I mean your bodies are designed to get rid
of those so you know really working on trying to expel the toxins but I think you'd have to
address the flukes first if you were diagnosed with them but but then again if you get your body
working the way god designed it I mean there's they're going to be taken care of okay guys thank you
so much for joining me it was a pleasure if you have any other questions based on this or anything
I kind of popped into your mind feel free to post on Facebook I'll be monitoring that and I will
share some of the things we talked about and we'll have this as a live recording in a couple hours
thank you all right thanks guys all right good bye